sometime in the late 15th century The
Fortress that would eventually come to
be known as aaban was created in these
times it wasn't a prison it was
something much worse in fact after it
was eventually taken over by the
ministry of magic those who had
investigated refused to speak of the
horrors they' found within among those
Horrors possibly the darkest most vile
creatures in all of the Wizarding World
how it these creatures were not only
allowed to stay at aaban but given full
control as guardians of a new Wizard
prison it all begins with an incredibly
powerful sorcerer by the name of AC
Christus who once called aaban his home
thanks to his numerous concealment
charms the island in the North Sea
didn't appear on any map it's even
possible acrus created it himself here
he practiced the worst kinds of dark
magic setting aaban up as a death trap
for way W muggle Sailors he would lure
them to the island torture them and
eventually kill them the krisus was
never caught or punished for his crimes
Ministry officials only found the island
after his death which finally lifted the
elaborate concealment charms that had
been in place they would have felt the
Dementors long before they actually laid
eyes on them a bitter cold and ominous
Darkness would have permeated across the
entire Island the creatures feed on
positive human emotions leaving anyone
in their presence with fear doubt and
hopelessness deminers are among the
foulest creatures that walk this Earth
they infest the darkest filthiest places
they glory in Decay and despair they
drain Peace Hope and happiness out of
the air around them even Muggles feel
their presence though they can't see
them get too near to Menor and every
good feeling every happy memory will be
sucked out they are essentially
depression personified as Rowling has
described on more than one occasion
citing her own personal bouts with
depression as a reference point for
their very creation their sheer presence
could sap away the hope of any human
nearby but it's their kiss that was to
be feared Above All Else where there
should have been eyes there was only
thin gray scabbed skin stretched blankly
over empty sockets but there was a mouth
a gaping shapeless hole sucking the air
with the sound of a death rattle the
dementor's kiss would not simply Kill by
pulling back its hood and locking its
jaws onto the mouth of an unfortunate
victim the dementor could suck out the
very soul of a human you can exist
without your soul you know as long as
your brain and heart are still working
but you'll have no sense of self anymore
no memory no anything there's no chance
at all of recovery you'll just exist as
an empty shell and and your soul is gone
forever lost it's clear throughout
history how Wizards struggle to
understand these creatures capable of
inflicting a fate even worse than death
they actually aren't classified as
beasts by the ministry nor are they
considered beings they fall into a much
smaller category known as non beings
along with boggards and poltergeists
they're closely linked with humans and
our emotions like poltergeists and
bogerts their creation and existence
only seem possible as a direct result of
our human emotions some have speculated
that Dementors were created by AC
Christus and the atrocities he committed
at aaban others have theorized they
existed before then but worked alone or
in smaller numbers but there's no doubt
the concentration of Dementors in and
around aaban was unlike anything The
Wizarding World had ever encountered
before upon discovering the island
Wizards were left with a complex problem
and no easy solutions what should be
done with aaban and the horde of
creatures that they clearly knew so
little about unsurprisingly there were
many who argued for what may seem like
the most logical response destroy the
island and everything in it and therein
lies a significant problem you see
Dementors cannot be killed so what would
happen if Wizards were to destroy the
very place they call home even with
aisus dead and no longer luring Muggles
to a Grizzly demise the Dementors
remained infatuated with the place
clinging to the very walls that echoed
nothing but misery and pain wizard kind
understandably feared their retribution
to their credit the ministry sought the
opinion of magical experts experts who'
studied ancient buildings haunted by
dark magic their findings and
recommendations however did little to
bring Clarity to the situation some of
those consulted believed aaban May
unleash its own dark revenge on anyone
who dared attempt to destroy it the
Wizards were unable to reach a consensus
thus asaman remained abandoned for years
as a a breeding ground for Dementors so
it would seem that even without a supply
of living souls to feed upon the
hopelessness and despair was so deeply
rooted in aaban that the Dementors were
able to multiply for years on end
perhaps similar to the way Hogwarts is
known as a source of ancient magic as
caban would seem to be a source of dark
magic in some ways leaving the Dementors
to themselves actually worked for nearly
two centuries we have no record of any
major issues arising from their presence
on the island but in the late 17th
century the international statute of
secrecy changed everything as the witch
hunts grew ever fissa Wizarding families
began to live double lives using charms
of concealment to protect themselves and
their families by the 17th century any
witch or wizard who chose to fraternize
with Muggles became suspect even an
outcast in his or her own Community
First they tried working with the
British monarch to enact new muggle laws
granting protection for witches and
wizards when these efforts failed
Wizarding Society searched for a
solution some argued for allout war
against Muggles cooler heads ultimately
prevailed and they instead chose to go
into hiding the international statute of
secrecy would mean a totally new way of
life for wizards as they would be forced
to hide their presence from the larger
world all with the hopes of protecting
magical practitioners from Muggles after
the laws passing however they recognized
a significant security risk in having
multiple wizard prisons scattered across
the Country Escape attempts were
frequent and often drew the attention of
Muggles living nearby then Minister for
Magic ulick gamp the first man to ever
hold the post laid out plans for a new
dedicated and much larger prison to be
built on a remote herrian island all the
while debates continued to rage
concerning the new law of secrecy a
palpable sense of anger remained among
many Wizards frustrated they were being
forced into hiding so in 1718 before
gamp had begun constructing the new
prison The Wizarding World elected a new
Minister for magic democ R came to power
behind a staunch anti-muggle agenda he
quickly abandoned gamp's plans and
instead suggested they use aaban and its
Dementors to their advantage he argued
the ministry would save time and money
if they could work with the Dementors
and have them function as prison guards
which suggests Wizards knew of a method
by which they could communicate and
perhaps even bargain with the dangerous
non- beings even with opposition Ral
refused to waver on his decision as
caban became the new Wizard prison soon
enough prisoners started to arrive early
returns appeared positive the smaller
prisons for wizards were closed which
helped to remedy the concern of having a
prison in such close proximity to
Muggles not to mention the criminals
were never seen or heard from again the
Dementors of aaban were nothing if not
incredibly effective at keeping the
prisoners secure at least for a Time
percus Parkinson followed as Minister
and he too supported using asaman as a
prison when eldrich diory took over as
Minister the prison had been up and
running for 15 years with no breakouts
and not a single breach of security
allow me to introduce myself so few
students know who I am these days eldrid
diur former Minister for magic and
founder of the aura recruitment program
at your service from the outside
everything seemed to be going well but
diory wanted to see things for himself
so he took a trip to inspect aaban and
he was appalled at what he found the
conditions were unimaginable the
prisoners he found were nearly all
insane those that were still alive that
is others had already died of Despair
and were buried at a newly constructed
graveyard Upon returning to London diory
immediately began working with the
committee to come up with alternatives
to aaban and its Dementors even after
hearing about the horrible conditions
experts warned diory as to what would
happen if the Dementors were suddenly
deprived of the constant supply of solds
the experts argued it was the only
reason they remained mostly confined to
the island should digory deprive them of
that after it was already agreed upon
years earlier under Ral it's possible
the Dementors would now abandon the
prison and head for the mainland digory
however persisted having witnessed and
felt the conditions firsthand he
continued to implore they come up with
Alternatives tragically digory
contracted Dragon pox and died with his
death the fervor with which he'd argued
for a solution more Humane died with him
in
1747 more than 200 years would follow
with 30 ministers taking office all of
them turned a blind eye to aaban with
its perfect record of no escapes it
became easier and easier to justify some
even went as far as magically enlarging
the prison to house even more prisoners
but there were some who understood the
serious risks this Arrangement posed
some who understood the nature of the
Dementors better than others the rest of
us sleep be blessed soundly in our beds
Cornelius knowing that you have put Lord
Voldemort's most dangerous supporters in
the care of creatures who will join him
the instant he ask them said Dumbledore
they will not remain loyal to you fudge
Voldemort can offer them much more scope
for their powers and their Pleasures
than you can it shouldn't surprise that
of all the Wizards we know from lore
Albus Dumbledore would have some of the
best and most accurate insight to the
true nature of the Dementors Dumbledore
had long disapproved of using them as
guards and was equally frustrated when
they were stationed near Hogwarts to
track down serious black as readers we
first encounter them just before Harry's
third year when they bored the Hogwarts
Express in search of black an intense
cold swept over them all Harry felt his
own breath catch in his chest the cold
went deeper than his skin it was inside
his chest it was inside his very heart
Harry's eyes rolled up into his head he
couldn't see he was drowning in cold
there was a rushing in his ears as
though of water he was being dragged
downward The Roaring growing louder as
we learn throughout the rest of the book
Harry is even more susceptible to the
dementor's presence because his memories
are so much darker than most every time
he's in their presence he's forced to
relive the night Voldemort attacked his
family and left him with his famous scar
we get another firsthand look at the
dementor stretching the limits of their
freedom when they show up during a
quidditch match between Gryffindor and
Hufflepuff once again their presence
affects Harry far more than the others
nearby and he passes out in the middle
of the match nearly falling all the way
to the ground Dumbledore was really
angry minione said in a quaking voice
I've never seen him like that before he
ran onto the field as you fell waved his
wand and you sort of slowed down before
you hit the ground then he whed his wand
at the Dementors shot silver stuff at
them they left the stadium right away he
was Furious they'd come onto the grounds
the silver spell is of course the
Patronus charm one of the few ways of
Defending against a dimin Mentor but the
only reason Dementors were even at
Hogwarts is because they'd experienced
their first ever escape from aaban or so
they thought in Harry's fourth year it's
revealed that one of Voldemort's Death
Eaters B Crouch Jr actually pulled off
the feet years before serus black his
father bardy senior was a power hungry
Ministry official who took great pride
in ruthlessly punishing those found
guilty of aiding Voldemort his career
and ambition consumed him he realized
far too late that his own son had joined
the ranks of those he'd come to despise
and so he treated him to the same
punishment he'd handed out to so many
others a lifelong sentence to aaban but
B senior's reputation was forever
blemished his own son being found guilty
of working for Voldemort was enough to
destroy his once promising hopes of one
day becoming Minister for magic he was
demoted from his position as Council of
magical law and the subject of rampant
gossip to make matters worse for B
senior he had a terminally ill wife at
home now grief stricken at the loss of
her son and in what had to be one of his
weakest moments she pleaded with him for
one final favor you see B senior was
likely more familiar with d mentors than
most perhaps he even visited as caban
himself and as such he would have been
well aware they cannot see instead they
feel their way towards people by sensing
their emotion Crouch senior arranged for
he and his wife to visit aaban no doubt
playing this off as a mother's final
wish to see her son one last time with
Mrs Crouch already near death herself
the Dementors would have simply detected
one near- dead person going in with B
Senor and one near dead person going out
with B Senor as an extra precaution in
case other prisoners were watching
Crouch Senor used poly juice potion to
switch the two of them apparently he
left some behind for her to continue
taking as she died just a few days later
still bearing the appearance of her son
this Escape was so carefully planned and
executed that it went completely
undetected for 13 years sirus's Escape
wasn't as carefully planned but still
showcases another weakness in the
dementor's abilities even though he
spent 12 years inside the prison black
knew he was innocent holding on to this
fact helped him maintain a small piece
of his sanity over the years considering
this wasn't exactly a happy thought for
Sirius the Dementors weren't able to
take it away black was also an
unregistered animus and anytime he
transformed into a dog his feelings
thoughts and emotions were mostly
undisturbed you see Dementors only feed
off human emotions as a dog his feelings
registered to them as being less human
less complex even so black was weak and
feared he couldn't risk an escape
without a wand but everything changed
when black spotted Peter pedru in his
rat form on the front page of the daily
prophet he spotted the prophet during
one of Cornelius fudge's prison and
inspections it was as if someone had let
a fire in my head and the Dementors
couldn't destroy it it wasn't a happy
feeling it was an obsession but it gave
me strength it cleared my mind so one
night when they opened up my door to
bring food I slipped past them as a dog
it's so much harder for them to sense
animal emotions and they were confused I
was thin very thin thin enough to slip
through the bars I swam as a dog back to
the mainland I Journey North and slipped
into the Hogwarts grounds as a dog
Black's Escape was nothing though
compared to what would come later
remember that Dumbledore was one of the
few who understood their true nature a
staunch opponent of even using them as
prison guards he understood them in a
way many did not and knew their
allegiance could change if someone were
to give them even more of what wizard
kind had offered so many years before
not to mention an added benefit of
roaming free and spreading to even more
parts of the world their loyalty would
be tested if only another could give
them even more of what what they craved
and that's exactly what Voldemort
promised them and as if that all wasn't
enough said fudge barely listening to
the Prime Minister we've got dor
swimming all over the place attacking
people left right and Center Once Upon a
happier time this sentence would have
been unintelligible to the Prime
Minister but he was wiser now I thought
dor God the prisoners in aaban he said
cautiously they did said fudge wearily
but not anymore they've deserted the
prison and joined he who must not be
named I won't pretend that wasn't a blow
but said the prime minister with a sense
of dawning horror didn't you tell me
that the creatures that drain hope and
happiness out of people that's right and
their breeding that's what's causing all
this Mist their numbers at aaban had
grown to the thousands but now the
Dementors previously wielded as a tool
by the ministry of magic served a new
master they even fought alongside him in
the Battle of Hogwarts of course Harry
Potter emerged Victor torious from here
there was no going back to the way
things were Kingsley shacklebolt took
over as the new Minister for magic after
so many years and so many Souls had been
sentenced away to askaban it was finally
time for things to change for the better
the Dementors were driven away from
aaban under kingsley's leadership the
location itself remains a prison in The
Wizarding World to this day ORS now
serve as the guards and they're
regularly rotated in from the mainland
there is yet to be any kind of a Escape
or breakout under this new setup as for
the Dementors we know they can't be
killed perhaps they were weakened and
now somewhat contained maybe they roam
the lands in smaller numbers still a
force not to be taken lightly but
nowhere near as strong as when they work
in large groups or perhaps they're still
out there searching for a new dark
location to call their home once
[Music]
more